why why are you looking at me because
I'm waiting for you to do something like
dig dig dig dig dig dig dig dig dig I'm
not just like a content machine I can't
top myself each one pink dink dink dink
dink dink comedy comedy - I thought one
more danger Wow welcome to the podcast
my name is Julien stop introducing
yourself oh I don't like this new thing
where you introduce yourself the only
reason why weird well the only reason
why I did it again that's because cuz
you don't like it oh thank you I love
that about you
my friend build your website with
Squarespace
[Laughter]
seriously Squarespace is a great product
you should use it to build your website
go to Squarespace comm slash Jenna
Julian save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain or give it a free
trial 24/7 customer support amazing
service also guys me Indies the softest
underwear in the world expanding their
arsenal to bra let's socks even doggie
bandanas that they just sent out to us
oh my god they're so nice
they have boxer briefs they have apples
collections they have onesie designs all
time go to meet undies calm meu n di es
calm Sasha and Julian get 15% off your
first pair of free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee thank you
sponsors this podcast marks a very
important milestone I'd say so for us
for us and we didn't think it was gonna
be like this no there's a greyhound in
the room a full-size greyhound you
remember the podcast that we did where
we scratched off like $1 lottery tickets
so that maybe someday we could afford a
house so that we could have a greyhound
I remember that I put the racing
greyhounds in the background and now
we're doing a podcast with a greyhound
in the room we're telling the truth
I don't know I can't see her but we're
telling the truth here no there's what
we'll do ready okay yeah go ahead and I
watch this watch this ingenuity right
here okay you guys can see my phone
right okay they can't acting as a mirror
they can't see that especially not if
they're listening to the cause I'm
looking dude this is not working no oh
that's above the frame no this is not
okay here ready look it's on camera look
flip to the side take a picture look
back most recent picture okay Wow where
all of me oh my bunny our new greyhound
that we adopted if you are under Iraq
and you haven't heard we adopted our own
greyhound this week Jenna made a whole
really really well put together
comprehensive video where we filmed the
process from basically a whole week from
the moment actually it was five days I
think yeah I guess it was five days of
filming we got we started filming the
moment we got the call that she was you
know recommended to us to be our adopted
dog all the way until like two days ago
three days ago we did it we got a
greyhound her name is bunny
and we're gonna talk about that today
because I feel like that's like a huge
life thing that we should talk about
totally well in her ears or she has a
tattoo I think she was you know in the
racing registry yeah but then that she
never raced and then was a blood donor
dog but she has her birthday tattooed in
her ear she's three years old now and
her birthday tattoo says six eight one
five five which means June 8th is her
birthday and she is the fifth puppy or
litter but that before still makes her a
Gemini and it still makes Kermit's
birthday last we afford our dogs all
Gemini's and Kermit still has the last
birth
it's like another birthday he has to
endure in order to get to his birthday
remember that when we forgot his
birthday like we actually forgot that it
was his birth we remembered that day
it's not like we completely forgot about
but we remembered as in like we were on
the way to our workout we're like oh
[ __ ] today's Crimmins birthday whereas
my Elizabeth day we wake up we're like
the pet store the whole day we're taking
off work our workouts we're not doing
anything it's all about you
meanwhile really oh yeah it's Kermit's
birthday so this is a big deal because
this is the marbles crawling over marble
we're just trying to give her her space
so forgive us if we're also dog
babysitting the whole time hey mumble oh
do you want to come up in your spot
sorry there was some dog kissing and
loving going on in there
three little dogs bed and so he was on
his spot but let me get him in his back
so we we didn't expect bunny to be in
this room with us right now we were
recording so she's had a hard time with
like every room you know like our
bedroom I think she was super easy about
but the kitchen she's not really
ventured too much into the living room
she's getting better about exploring a
little more curious front hall the
office room hasn't gone in the dining
room she likes to sit in the game room
with us at this point but she like when
we were about to record the podcast we
were like you know what should we do
with bunny like me we she knows she's
comfortable on her bed in the living
room she's also very comfortable sitting
on the pool lounger outside but if we're
not gonna be able to supervise her we're
not gonna leave her out there obviously
but so we were like maybe we put her on
the bed downstairs or you know we come
upstairs we were fully prepared to sort
of have the camera set up so we could
baby monitor her while she's sitting on
the cushion downstairs her bed and she
followed us up the stairs and wanted to
come in here and this is like I know you
guys can't see but there's like big
lights you know camera there's a TV
screen and a computer monitor was a
little fan you what what else
in the corner of the room two boxes of
polyfills yes you forgot that part sorry
I just wanted to hey you're hoarding
polyfill in our podcast room we have
gotten rid of the jeans yet every guest
that's why you know our house since that
video has thought maybe we're collecting
people's bottom halves I'm very thankful
that Bunny hasn't decided that those
pairs of jeans was stuffing in them and
not toys I'm thankful for that too
so she followed us in here and we so you
know have not really worked on the TV
screen thing with her but for some
reason she's not perceiving the monitor
as a TV screen right now umm she's okay
with computer screens well yeah the TV
in the living room is like really big
and really high but it's in the living
room it's pronounced it's the only thing
on the wall this this is hidden by a
giant lights oh yeah I'm sure it
actually is mainly hiding it and then
there's sound foam too and she's kind of
in the corner so I don't think she
actually sees the screen I feel like if
she were to maybe see it it might
startle her a little bit but would I was
we we were not expecting her to be in
here while we recorded so we're both
very pleasantly surprised today has been
like a monumental day for her she's made
so many strides today specifically like
we're working with her in today's day
seven today's day seven and it's like
the first day where we feel like okay
this is progress
yeah but we're working with her all day
like we haven't we haven't gone to a
workout for a week I've barely trained
you Jitsu I mean we're like our lives
are kind of on hold right now because
we're raising this girl and we're
teaching her how to be a dog and so
every day were taking her for a walk but
even just like getting to the point or
we're like feeding her or like walking
her outside everything takes a very long
time right now like a walk that would
usually take us about 40 minutes is not
taking us out and a half or two hours
and getting there is a process and
getting her to eat is a process every
day she's timid and scared and needs
help you know and we're too you know
we're trying our best to focus on the
small little victories each day but
today was a very good day and it it's no
surprise that today's the day she wanted
to just follow us up here because she
wanted to be with us she walked up the
stairs all by herself
yeah if you've watched the video you
know that she didn't
how to walk upstairs so the fact that a
week later she's taking a whole flight
of stairs by herself it's awesome
but so she's sitting in the corner shows
like corners that makes her feel safe
and she likes her crate but she's
sitting in her bed sleeping no she's not
she's pretty tired yeah we did a lot
today yeah we've been going on the long
walks and man it's been it's been a one
of the most intense weeks of my life
mm-hmm I think and I'm so happy I'm like
so I'm starting to feel a little bit
relieved yeah you know like the relief
is finally coming yeah I was a mix of
emotions going on very intense emotions
going on that first week I cried almost
every single day yeah we've had her I
haven't cried today proud of myself I
hope soon they turn into like a really
really happy tears you know what I'm
saying no it's it's really stressful and
you know I talked about it in the video
but literally yesterday like had broke
down to Rome because she was here and I
was like crying it was like you know a
mess and everything's very overwhelming
because she was resource guarding inside
which means something a toy or food or a
bed those are your dog's resources and
if they perceive them as mine you know
and they feel like that's being
threatened like maybe you give a dog a
bone or rawhide or whatever you try and
take it from them and they growl at you
you know if you have a little dog it's
whatever and these guys have all sorted
that out amongst themselves and they
don't resource guard with us or with
each other really if anything peach
steals Kermit's chew and then permits
its at me and screams until I take it
back and even if you know our piggies
and marbles whatever resource card
anything there's very low stakes
no one's getting hurt you know they have
an established pack dynamic dynamic in a
hierarchy but even so they're all small
dogs and they're all relatively harmless
one of them has no teeth one of them has
no teeth Kermit is losing teeth you know
each year peachie is you know she yeah
she's the most beta girl in the world
so yeah introducing a big dog let alone
a greyhound rescue has been has been a
whole big old challenge for everybody
right and like one of the
most positive experiences with well the
organization crave in particular but I
imagine a lot of adoption agencies is
that they don't say okay congratulations
here's your dog and then you know that's
it they gave us resources and one of
those was a dog behaviorist she
behavioral trainer yeah yeah
her name is Bonnie she's incredible and
she just like you know she lives an hour
away from here and she volunteers her
time because you know gray save like a
lot of dog adoption agencies that you
know it's a nonprofit yeah they might
have someone that can help you but you
know if we lived near her obviously I
think she would you know come over and
help us she does it for the service like
in general just to do right by the dogs
but because we live an hour away
she just had like an hour long phone
call with Julian and I was gone but like
an hour long phone call just talking to
you and just helping you and you know
giving you good information and there's
so many really good resources online
like I've been looking at the forum like
gray talk a lot and there's a lot of
people that not only normalize your
experiences but also you know help you
work through them you know and it's just
really it was invaluable to have someone
to speak on the phone with you well also
being able to answer your personal
questions for your personal situation
you know and it was just like it's given
us really like a lot of confidence and
we've had success with that like right
away yeah and I think one of the things
that makes an organization like grace a
special is that like you said it's you
know it's not any other adoption agency
or rescue or whatever where they give
you the dog they're like thanks you did
great I don't know there's a lot like a
ton of those well I'm just saying always
try and give resource oh yeah sure yeah
hopefully sure this is my first rescue
ever and this is my first experience
with anything like this and obviously we
kind of jumped into the deep end with
you know a greyhound is a very complex
dog to rescue especially when they're
timid and they have been to the track
and whatever it's just a cobbler gentle
natured and they like to be trained
gently they're gentle but the
you know this is something that we as
much as we wanted to do and we've talked
about it we love greyhounds we love the
breed it's not an easy quick okay we got
a greyhound now they're sweet and other
part of the family everything's fine
it's it's a very it's a very intense
process and what I was saying is you
know having an organization like Rai
save facilitate these adoptions the way
they do with the foster homes with the
volunteer veterinarians with the
volunteer behavioral therapists and
trainer like all of these resources that
they give you and the fact that they're
checking in on you so we don't have to
feel alone
yeah I mean it's a it's a scary process
in the beginning and so yeah we've we've
been very like fortunate and happy that
they've kind of helped us through this
whole thing but yeah i sat on the phone
with bonnie yesterday for an hour and
you know just hearing the way she was
wording things and how she was
explaining kind of the dynamics and how
dogs perceive things in ways that you
kind of wouldn't really think about
unless you're Jenna and you're
researching this [ __ ] all day and night
it was really helpful and even today and
last night actually I was starting to
put some of it into practice and to see
it actually work and to see little
things click for both bunny and myself
just the world the world of difference
and it encourages me and you so much
more and I don't think it was a
coincidence that the day after that call
is our best day with her yet and yeah
you know I think he's a lot of things
that fed to that but yeah yeah I mean I
like I have cried over bunny over things
like you know her being very feel
fearful and how hard it is to watch a
dog that's you know scared because it
just breaks my heart but I also you know
cried because of the the resource
guarding with the toy which we've tested
a couple times inside and outside and
outside she's okay because she's relaxed
you know it's not filled with people
things now she loves to be out so she
just yeah she was okay with the toy and
uh inside when she's in her bed and she
knows she's a little stressed and she's
a little excited and now I finally get a
toy and this is mine and she's a dog
that's never like had stuff you know
like I'm so excited I finally get my own
toy you know and greyhounds stay with
their siblings for a lot longer
than other dogs when they're in that
racing environment and you know that's
their communication with each other
that's acceptable communication with
each other like I growl at you as loud
as I can until you run away and I take
this piece of food and this is fine you
know but with people obviously your
first reaction is to be frightened by it
you know it was scary the first couple
times that we heard her resource guard
and that you know made me cry later cuz
I'm a big soft weak [ __ ] but I feel
terrible that what an enjoyable
experience for you to play with a toy
and I want you to have that toy and I
want to play with you and I want to like
enjoy my time with you I love you you
know and it hurts my heart that you
think like I'm gonna take it from you
and not give it back like what what a
terrible thing for her to have to feel
and you know we worked a lot today on
positive reinforcement on the walk and
you know when she is being curious like
when she came up here and it's just like
a bunch of yes like bunny good yeah and
she's starting to respond yeah yeah and
when she's like being curious and
walking around like it's a great time to
give her positive reinforcement because
we can't do that when she's being
fearful and you know running away and
that's not a good time to give praise
cuz that's reinforcing yes be scared you
know yeah but uh you know we had a
really good day and we tested the
resource guarding again and a lot of it
has to do with just basic trust with us
like if I don't know you I'm not gonna
give you this toy back who are you don't
take this from me but you know the more
she knows us and trusts us I have so
much hope that this is something that's
gonna be way less of an issue in the
future yeah yeah and it's just really
rewarding to see sort of like the first
steps of you know your hard work with
her like starting to pay off because you
know when you rescue a dog we have a
puppy you get like love immediately you
know it's like oh my god yeah and then
when you have a rescue dog it takes a
long time to get some love back yeah but
when you do it just feels so special and
rewarding yeah
you know yeah um one of the things that
we're really grateful for is you know
obviously like everything in life we're
very grateful to be able to share this
experience with you and the Internet
partially because it's exciting and we
want you guys to know about our lives
and everything but also because like
Jenna was saying like having you guys
chime in about your experiences it's
helpful it is helpful and normalize is
it makes us feel like we're not in this
alone and that other people have done
this and have had the same struggles in
a comment that I've seen you know around
a lot ever since we announced bunny is
from people who have both adopted and
rescued greyhounds but also just adopted
and rescued other dogs explaining that
like that first that first bit of time
when you're just like so lost and you're
so frustrated in your sad all of these
emotions - like any sort of improvement
whether it's a month a year two years
ten years later like that makes it worth
it and that's what people have been
saying and it's just like man like you
know it really helps it does it does
because look how far we've come in one
week you know and that feeling that we
have of like man we're actually doing it
you know she's improving she's getting
happier and more comfortable you know
it's it's a very I guess something that
you can't really explain to someone you
kind of just have to go through it yeah
and we're going through it yeah it was a
lot I would categorize this first week
as one of the hardest things I've ever
really done like college softball very
difficult graduate school pretty
difficult you know I mean there's a lot
of you in a gray house oh my god I'm
gonna cry cry cry cry but there's so
many things in your life that you've
done right that are hard on paper and
they're challenging but at least for you
there is one there is like you visualize
a path of like okay how am I gonna do
this and then that's it and then you do
it and it's up to you and it's a hard
it's hard but this is like it's a lot
different cuz you're like okay this is
what I do this is the right thing and
then it's like oh no she growled
oh no she's sad oh no she's scared what
am i doing what am i doing well you
start to doubt yourself and that becomes
a whole other those are some of the
things that you know she needs to go
through in order to get to the trusting
loving she that yeah you know we all
deserve but you know there was a time
there when I was when she's resource
guarding I was very scared of you know
don't show her that I'm scared and I
don't we do a thing called trading up
where that's how you teach drop it and
you know when she has the toy and she's
resource guarding and growling you
respect that growl and you back off but
then it's like hey look at this
beautiful punch beat that I have this
way more exciting than you toy you know
and she's like oh and then you're just
throwing a drop in there and all the
sudden she's learning drug right exactly
but you know it's it's hard in those
moments with a dog that you know you've
only had for a week that's like get the
[ __ ] away from me when I'm like I love
you I love dogs like I just want to love
you and it's hard sometimes you know I
just want to hug you and kiss you and
cuddle you but like I know you're not
ready for that right now I know but you
know she is like we've talked a lot
about like how she's kind of the perfect
talk well the Greyhound is the perfect
dog for us why we we adopted a girl
who's wanted a greyhound we have other
sight hounds which are a little
different but we've always thought that
this is like the perfect dog for our
lives
yeah we you know tell why well y'all
already know we both work from home we
walk a1 group of dogs once to maybe
twice a day but we're home and we're
lounging and we're whether we're working
or we're chilling or we're kind of in
one place and greyhounds and design
greyhounds they like to loaf they like
to chill and they like to be near and
they like to be near you and all of
those things are completely possible and
realistic with our situation we're not
going to an office we don't have to go
film on said there's nothing like
aliment world we can be there with them
pretty much all day every day
barring any sort of trip or whatever
that we're taking and we go to the
grocery store and we go to the gym and
you know we do all of like you know
normal amount of leaving the house for
us and but it's not a nine-to-five and
you know not that there's anything wrong
with people that have dogs that have 9
to 5 s but it's or even greyhounds like
that right also it's a thing
people do but it's like because we are
home and we have a yard and it's fenced
in and you know we're here we have other
sight hounds well you know what they're
like and you know they have their own
special needs and quirks and just I
would love to have a dog that just wants
to loaf around at home get one good
like I'm gonna pants and get tired walk
and now if you want to go lay around so
that's what we're gonna do a to be here
we don't leave the house for super long
periods of time regularly yes usually
it's one of us leaving anyway well I
mean you guys have seen how Peach is
really pretty good but Kermit I think is
the perfect embodiment of a dog a sight
hound like they're your [ __ ] shadow
man like just he I haven't gone into a
room alone in nine years yeah you know
and I think a lot of people with
greyhounds whippets Italian Greyhounds
would tell you the same thing like they
they some of them are I guess not as
like that like peachy but she follows
you everywhere but yeah Carmen is just
glued to me
sometimes he knows how to orbit you to
where I I can't get him he's because he
knows what side of you to be on while
you're even moving it's very impressive
but it can be they can have separation
anxiety yeah it's a real thing yeah for
pound so yeah we're very just have like
a perfect situation for it to have a
sight home that needs a home yeah and
we're very early in the stages of
training her with leaving the house both
of us leaving the house we've done a
couple tests where we leave for a couple
minutes and we have the camera that you
know baby camera on her so we can watch
she doesn't care she really like all the
signs are there that this is going to be
good and we hope so I mean what what
makes me feel good is that you know when
we came up here to podcasts she follows
she wanted to be with us and that's like
the first time she's kind of shown that
for those of you who have rescued
animals like that that like moment of
like oh my god you want to come with us
like you know um but yet she hasn't
shown signs of separation anxiety but I
am glad that she wants to be with us
because we usually have three dogs in
this podcast room like
come on me girl we're already ready for
you to be here in the game room and you
know hanging out with us and like she's
so good about us streaming we we've
almost like desensitize her to our
stream room the only thing left to ready
fridge set over is the fridge we have
that makes one she doesn't mind the
sound of it being on but it makes like a
clicking noise every once in a while
that she's like excuse me
yeah but Jenna talked about the T like
TVs she's scared of a big living room TV
turn it on she really doesn't like it we
have to work on that I'll have to work
on that but we both told ourselves
they're like okay if we're gonna have
her in the stream room we need to show
her that monitors PC monitors are not
bad I'd say it only took her about ten
officially ten minutes we went up and we
brought her in the room he touched the
monitors were like it's okay we touched
them so she could see that it wasn't
hurting she sniffed them we turned to
mom we had game play going so she could
see the movement just kind of like her
understanding that it's just a flat
screen it's not gonna get her but she
got that really quick and now will
stream for our long streams as we do
last night we went like eight and a half
nine hours she chilling come on
that's amazing but she was sleeping yeah
that's what all these guys do let me
stream you're like okay um I'm down I'm
sitting right like marble sits in a spot
like this on my desk like facing me he
gets he gets good the whole time like
it's the same as you know if you come
home from work or whatever and you sit
on the couch with your dogs and I just
want to snuggle up to you it's like that
they're just on my desk they're on our
desk and we both have like fairly large
desks to where we can have more than
half of my desk is a dog bed well no all
of your desk is criminals get up from a
nap and stand on your keyboard like it's
his and then you just start you start
disconnecting from discord and like
karmic God that boy he needs to
understand boundaries which is peachy
futures showing more interest in her
because she's gaining confidence no you
know like dogs really respond well to
other socially confident dogs
and you know I think they could
obviously tell that she's having a hard
time so they're not over there being
like be my friend be my friend be my
friend you know yeah but she's getting
more confidence and even in here peachy
was like went over there and visited her
for a second not getting in her bed
saying hello yeah well speaking of
confidence you're not ever as confident
that could be when you're wearing - like
amazing amazing three times softer than
cotton underwear by me undies that was
you know I mean how can you get more
confident than that you're walking
around your bums supported you're
feeling nice and soft good airflow it's
just a great pair of underwear and you
could be wearing it and up your
confidence by two points BAM right at
the top then you get a nice design from
me undies they have new designs all the
time
they're working with cool artists bump
another two points your confidence just
went up four points on the scale
levelling up with me undies they just
dropped I
I'm stupid cuz I forgot the name it
something like buddies bunny buddy
bunnies something with bandanas for dogs
their dog bandanas dog bandanas and
there's they're literally the same
materials underwear so that are like so
soft and I put one on peach and she
looks so cute and it's like a light
material but me undies is truly just
something special they have amazing
underwear I can only imagine the bra
let's feel great I've never worn one I
mean if you want throw one on you if you
want to send me what it's so good I'll
put it on it feels so supported their
socks are my favorite just all the
greatest underwear literally three times
softer than cotton and you can try now
the new boxer brief with the fly which
is the same great cut as the boxer brief
but now with the added option of guys
who prefer to go through the gate versus
over the fence what what I'm just
sometimes you just gotta go through the
gate I'm just sitting if the options
there I'm going through the gate I'm
literally just don't even need a key
don't even need oh my god should we just
in the podcast there guys go to meet on
these meu and
is calm /in and julian get 15% off your
first pair of free shipping in
satisfaction hundred percent guaranteed
you will not be sorry I promise also
guys if you're gonna build your website
do a Squarespace what a great service to
build an awesome looking website without
having to learn a whole bunch or crazy
[ __ ] that you think you might need to
learn Squarespace makes it easy
they have 24/7 customer support
literally live customer support so if
you in the middle of the night stuck on
a problem they'll help you they also
have live webinars so you can join the
live webinar and pick up all sorts
careful the he's sleeping he might not
like that I've made a clicking noise and
then touched his bed he knows I'm coming
I'm like you can learn a whole bunch of
different things from the online
webinars that they have designing and
maintaining website can be overwhelming
with fonts images plugins hosting
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
that makes it really easy to do that and
they give you options have all sorts of
different pre-built templates that you
can modify make it look certain ways on
mobile and tablets and you can have
online stores and shops built in your
website as well check it out is a really
really great service you can do a free
trial right now or you can get 10% off
of your first purchase of a website or
domain when you go to Squarespace squ a
RESP a see e-comm slash Jenna Julianne
or click the link in the description
below what are you doing Thank You
sponsors but getting a little Brigades
completely oh boy you can try do you
know why we call him Berg ace because we
called him he's a ham he likes to ham it
up he's a hamburguesa thing just case a
case up people comment on a video or
picture and they're like oh look at the
bird gaze and I'm like but it's like
we've definitely said it embrace a case
of
rubba straighten your leg good boy what
the hell why do you have to straighten
his leg yes okay you know that's like a
lot of energy for him this is his speed
right now he's just trying to Oh Bunny's
also learning in my yellow she knows
that what it sounds like when I'm gaming
and I scream you don't scream well I
don't scream but I laugh really loud
yeah it's like loud laughter she's
getting accustomed to it you did like a
wheeze laughs last night and she got up
and was like yeah I would say that like
a new sound that she hasn't heard before
like she'll get up and she's a little
like I don't know what's going on yeah
but uh I mean we're being cautious with
the sounds like even when you're
clapping to do this you're like watching
her like yeah yeah yeah he's honestly
like a lot of sounds are pretty okay for
her she's more kind of interested in
sights but yeah they're I mean like the
first time I did the dishes or made a
smoothie like she was like she was cool
with the blender okay
I was shocked yeah I mean a lot of the
things that we really kind of envision
as being triggering for the dogs like
sound ah he's not and then things that
you don't think are yep no like she the
the walk that we go on there's like a
baseball field that has like a dugout or
like a building that's the announcer's
booth and it's painted blue but it's
just a building just like a square
building and she's really scared of it
mm-hmm so it's like right in the
beginning of our walk so we get out and
she sees it she was much better today
but like it's it's stuff that you just
don't even think twice about and I'm
thinking about making her a little like
just thing that goes around her neck and
over her back with iron-on letters it
says I'm training while we're out in the
world because people are being a little
annoying yeah too funny bonnie is
standing in front of you know we have
four dogs we're walking them one of us
walks three the other walks bunny right
and these guys have all been really
really really good about we need to take
a lot of breaks like a lot of standing
there a lot of working with bunny so
it's not just like we're walking around
the park you know it's like a lot of
stop and go and stop and go
stop and go and so Bunny's pretty scared
of the this one particular building and
so we're standing there for you know a
while and we're just talking and she's
being good and she's like looking and
watching and then you know she'll have
moments of like okay I want to turn
around and I don't want to look and then
you know encouraging to beat her to be
curious again and like you know watch
and look and watch me working on watch
me working on a lot of yes and you know
when she's being you know inquisitive
without fear and um so we're doing that
and this woman just walks by with her
dog and she just keeps shouting at us
he's friendly he's friendly and it was
at a time when bunny was turned around
from the building and I was like okay
thank you uh you know we're not gonna
have the meet any dogs she's just scared
of that building you know like I said
thought that you wouldn't think about
either but I'm like I appreciate that
you dog friendly but like it's amazing
to me that you can't read any dog body
language like we're standing here like
looking at our dog not talking to her
yeah like working with her you know and
yet you need to scream at me she's
friendly come me my dog like lady no not
right now we're in the middle of
something
yeah it's that's definitely something
that we're running into yeah like when
when Bunny's a little afraid we were at
the pet store with her getting another
bed and you know there's a lot there's
like cars driving by and stuff and you
know little bits of it are okay and then
when she starts to get in that like I'm
a little overwhelmed and I want to leave
you know it's you're not gonna do a lot
of desensitizing she needs to be curious
not you know fearful yeah so when she
gets into that it's like okay sensory
overload let's let's move on we can keep
working on this we don't it doesn't need
to be solved right away you know we just
yeah and this woman just comes up to her
and he's asking us a million questions
and you know Julian's like helping her
and you know turning her around and like
doing this just trying to make sure
she's nice commander the fight-or-flight
panic yeah and this woman's touching her
and she's just like she cannot read that
Julian is trying to work with bunny in
this given moment and instead is only
just like could be a baby oh yeah
spite the fact and despite the fact that
we're not really you know particularly
confrontational people if someone steps
out of line I'm happy to like stand up
for myself
I don't like seek out confrontation like
some people and so on top of the fact
that we don't like to do that it's not
good energy for her to be around so if
someone's like you know stepping on our
toes and I'm like hey back off like
that's not good for bunny to be around
because she's like okay my owners now
making her a little thing that just says
I'm training so then if people are like
looks like a service dog then almost
like people can look at the thing I
wanted to be very homemade-looking so
that people are not confusing her with a
service dog but also that like you don't
have people that are trying to overstep
their boundaries or some sort of sign a
very clear message that's like you know
if we're stopped and standing and your
dog is excited to meet us maybe you take
one second and maybe ask the person cuz
usually a lot of people around here are
just like okay my dog wants to meet your
dog so here we go or my dog is off leash
yeah we see a lot of people around here
that just don't abide by leash laws
whatsoever no it's optional for like
everyone that's obviously a concern but
but I think something like that that
just says I'm training that's like just
yeah one step all y'all that just don't
read any kind of dog language whatsoever
I'm trained just like then you'll ask
you'll talk you'll ask us first you know
what I mean you had an auction are you
auctioning off your dog she's friendly
like this my dog looked like she wants
to play right now she's she's looking at
a building and she's a little scared can
you just let it look at the building
what if I had to tell it between my legs
right now yeah and I have no problem
being like yeah right now we're focusing
on working on the building the she's
friendly dogs so and out of ten you dogs
ten out of ten the friendly one is
amazing because like before we had bunny
I was walking the dogs
and this like medium-sized dog just like
kind of fast trots over to marbles to
the point where marble gets freaked out
and actually makes a sound like a
pre-emptive sound so I scooped him up
yeah like back off back off and so I
scooped him up and the dogs like kind of
marble up oh just because he got spooked
well the dog was going right for my okay
and marble like made a pre-emptive sound
OH scooped him up this dog off leash off
leash Oh scoop I love to save marble and
30 seconds later the guy walks over and
says oh she's friendly well actually
first of all that doesn't matter because
the your dogs off leash in and a leash
dog in a leashed human park and she
should be off leash so that is an
irrelevant detail and it's also a lie
because your dog charged at my tiny dog
whether or not they were trying to play
tomorrow's it was like scared shitless
so but I mean those friendly people okay
there's a reason why you have a leash
law it's to keep dogs safe and even if
your dog is friendly it's optional even
if your dog is friendly what I
appreciate is that how much we go on our
walks you see people that are working
with dogs especially on the bike path
that we go on because it's so quiet
we've seen now multiple dogs they're
people like really working hard with
dogs that are you know wild or really
growl and really bark at other dogs like
and I just appreciate those people so
much because those aren't the people
with their dogs off leash like imagine
you and your friendly dog walking past
that dog you know or charging that dog
yeah but it's a big problem and I just
feel really bad for the people that are
working so like bunnies a little fearful
but you know we're not dealing with a
dog that's super aggressive or like you
know angry on walks and you know needs a
lot of holding or you know what I mean
but I just feel for those people that
they're doing everything that they can
to protect their dog and work with their
dog and help them feel safe and
confident and comfortable on a walk and
then here comes Joe Schmoe with Heath
friendly and that could undo a bunch of
yeah you're undoing a bunch of progress
which isn't fair
you know that progress is hard knocks
man don't look at him like that who's
minding his own business
I just I can't believe I'm so proud of
her she's sleeping like with her teeth
out like like two Greyhound the picture
you took her first so freaking adorable
today she's very photogenic
it's funny how small her head looks in a
picture like her head is giant but when
you take a picture of her straight on it
looks like noses in focus and it just
looks like she looks like a Kermit yeah
looks like she might be pretty little
but then when you see her you're like
wow she's gigantic but she's not even a
gigantic greyhound
her foster brothers those are gigantic
greyhounds their horses they are horses
also like another amazing like I was
saying the foster situation where very
save will you know let people be foster
parents to dogs like the foster grew the
foster home it was amazing that we had
picked bunnies bunny up from from their
house when we picked her up amazing he's
amazing
incredible guy he has two greyhounds
that are his and he Foster's greyhounds
and he's a great with them and it's just
like incredible peace of mind it doesn't
feel like we've kind of just been like
left to deal with everything well and I
know like you know what he said to us
too like part of being a foster is
taking in dogs and getting you know
attached to them seeing that like the
very beginning progress you know I
imagine when he got bunny they were like
she was probably 20 times more timid I
don't want to give her back when we
because we're going on vacation soon and
he volunteered to watch her which has
made our life incredibly easy because
asking anyone to come to our house and
watch all for these guys is way too much
of a talker and so yeah I'm excited to
show him all of her progress and I'm
sure he's gonna be very excited but it's
it for him to you know not only take
care of an animal that's in need but
also then say goodbye to her is like
takes a lot it's like those people are
incredible and anyone that Foster's
animals like I I don't
it's amazing it's so much yeah I mean I
don't know how it goes with like the
rules of like if you fostering in them
for so long they're not adopted can you
adopt it or maybe that's how they got a
foster to adopt system yeah yeah but
still yeah you're right
like MVP for real unbelievable yeah well
a lot of like gray saver I imagine other
adoption agencies aren't like a
brick-and-mortar place like you can't go
there and go see their greyhounds it's
all donations and Fosters so without
Fosters we're they don't yeah they don't
have a place where the dogs go you know
what I mean so the system relies on
people like that and it's like it's a
hard job I'm sure it's a very rewarding
job but like man the real MVP yeah and
and so we get we get uh so we're we
should announce it on the podcast I told
you last week we're going out of town
for our first vacation of our lifetime
next not lifetime our first vacation
that we've ever taken together yeah I've
never I've never done a vacation yeah
like I've gone on trips but I've never
done a vacation trip yeah the kid we
actually did tell you I told you last
week so you're good but yeah we have a
whole nother week with her to work with
her and then we're going on vacation
we're gonna come back and keep working
with her and keep you guys posted on all
of what's going on and I'm gonna miss
her I'm gonna miss her yeah this is like
this is the most I don't feel so special
to have her in here and just chilling
and relaxing because we know that that's
what she is you know like I want I want
to get my Yaya's out and then I want to
lay around like a big loaf and it feels
so happy that she is feeling comfortable
to do that right now yep and as always
like thank you guys for supporting us
and being excited and happy for us with
this whole thing and we talked a lot a
little about it on stream but you know
you'll see her when you see her and
we'll do our best to kind of
with you but as we as were working with
her and training her and getting to know
her it might be a little it might be a
little less like the way we treat the
other dogs were just posting about them
and they're everything we're doing
everything we're making videos it's not
gonna be this with us constantly yeah so
we we know that like it's a different
situation so we appreciate you it's
kinda nice though
in all the moments that I've been like
man you know I'm giving bunny all the
space that she needs and I wish I could
go over there and comfort her and that
actually meant something right now when
really the thing that means the most of
her is just having a little space like I
have three other dogs that I'm like oh
my god come here I need a hug at the end
of a long day with money like peach will
come to me in bed and I'm like come here
let me give you some love you need some
love yeah then she leaves me to cuddle
with you oh why did you just wake up
like that Bob Bob you good fam okay
probably what I'm kidding I don't know
what it was himself up well I'll see you
guys next week for another podcast thank
you for hanging out and be good have a
good week
[Music]
you
[Music]